my kid's giggling at me got the family
standing by
my kid is go away son i hate you what's
going on everybody for first week feast
i'm sean evans and you're watching hot
ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by jeffrey dean morgan
he's played unforgettable roles in tv
and film perhaps most notably as negan
on the walking dead
big character reveal april 4th he also
has a new film as well it's called the
unholy a horror movie set to release on
april 2nd
jeffrey dean morgan welcome to the show
thank you so much john
pleasure to be here my friend how are
you feeling going into this like
are you a guy who enjoys spicy food i
feel pretty good
i felt really good before
uh today came you know what i mean like
watching your show i've always felt like
i could do it
and now that i'm looking at these wings
in front of me i
suddenly am i feel like i might throw up
a little bit
the classic i'm ready i feel you all
right
i like start that one that was nice
that's a good like uh
getting into the kidney side of the pool
i like it
so your survival skills really transcend
your acting work as evidence by you and
your family living on this hundred plus
acre farm in upstate new york where you
take care of an array of animals that
include highland cows
alpacas and emus over the past year
there's been a massive migration of new
yorkers to the hudson river valley
what's the easiest way to spot a city
slicker who maybe bought a pandemic
farmstead but didn't really think it
through yeah they drive a subaru
i don't know why i don't i think they're
like four wheel drive
uh the family will go nice in it but
they drive a subaru so i see a subaru
and i
am immediately like flipping them off in
the ongoing battle to keep your
livestock
safe what has been the animal adversary
for you that's been most formidable
because between the coyotes the crows
the bobcats it sounds like you really
have your hands full
uh it's a bobcat a story when we first
got the farm my outback were getting
attacked by a bobcat
and it was the middle of a horrible
winter when we had like six feet of snow
and i built an igloo on top of the barn
using hay bales
and slept out there all night with a
rifle trying to get this bobcat
and i didn't by the way the bobcat won
and it's still out there i see his
tracks we can follow his tracks during
the snow so
his days are numbered someday someday
which is the more ideal day in rhinebeck
is it the sinner class parade in the
winter or
spending a day at the old rhinebeck
aerodrome in the summer
yeah those are both pretty great i'm
going to have to go with the center
clouds parade
because it only happens once a year you
can visit there a couple times um
but centric laws is uh has a very
special place in
our family's heart for sure and um when
we first got to rhinebeck and that
wasn't that long ago it was like 10
years ago
maybe three to 500 people and i think
last year they had 37
000 people i would love to have you come
one time because uh you know
we've been in the parade a couple times
too so i i can pull some strings for you
and we got the candy store so i'll hook
you up with some hot chocolate buddy
get me on the float get me that
peppermint bark i am right there i am
right there do it
i was wondering where you came up with
the rhine back i mean i know you're good
and you do your research but
that's pretty good that you got into
that wine bag that's pretty [ __ ]
great
[Music]
oh yeah okay so for many people watching
today you're known as the bat
wielding cold-blooded killer negan from
the walking dead a character that was
once described by executive producer
david alpert as one of the greatest
villains
ever created for tv not to destroy the
show's mystique or anything but can you
give
us a hollywood special effects trade
secret
when it comes to the art of a zombie
massacre um a trade secret we have the
best in the world with
uh special effects makeup with greg
nicotero not only does he come up with
the
the zombie innovations and every week
there's a
zombie that is specialized and it's
unbelievable we've never seen it before
you'd be amazed how little we actually
touch the zombies
when we're killing them i'll give you a
little secret i went out of fred of the
camera frame today
with the crowbar after it looked like i
whacked the zombie
and dipped it into the crowbar into a
bucket of pig guts
come up with it and it looks like i had
just wiped out the zombie you know
um that's what i'm talking about all
sorts of little things like that but
really i think the
big secret we have is greg nicotero he
is
a genius when it comes to that
all right let's do it this one looks
delicious
yeah yeah oh oh this one i'm starting to
feel a little bit of um
i'm gonna sneak up on you it's uh yeah a
little bit of a step up
from those first two for sure
all the same not bad
so i have to applaud you for being able
to parlay your lifelong obsession with
graphic novels into a formidable acting
resume that includes not only the
walking dead but also the losers
supernatural as well as playing thomas
wayne i know that you have a background
in graphic design
is there a comic that stands out to you
from a purely just
artistic appeal perspective this is
probably going to be an obvious answer
for
for people that know me but probably
watchmen
um for a lot of reasons but i think
alan moore uh who wrote that
dave gibbons you drew watchman i think
the two of them together
was unlike anything else i think that
book really kind of pulled you in
when watchmen got in my hands that to me
was sort of the life changer
what do you find interesting about dark
superheroes because between your
character the comedian and watchmen your
love for the show the boys
it does seem like you're drawn to these
characters that have a capacity for evil
i heard my wife say this the other day i
don't even know who she was talking to
she wasn't even talking to me and it was
she wasn't talking about anything that
i've ever done
but she said something to the effect
that
a villain doesn't know he's a villain
even though there are some like very
nihilistic qualities to someone like the
comedian and
and negan as well what would happen to a
normal man who was thrown into an
extraordinary circumstance
they are the heroes of their story i
think that a good villain
has no idea that he's a villain although
he may
the only the only hiccup in that is they
may enjoy
doing the bad stuff a little bit more
than they ought to
hell fire devil's blend i mean there's a
couple things in there that
would give a fella pause
oh i got a question um
not that you have to it's not my job to
ask questions i guess but
what the hell did gordon ramsay have on
his show he had like a grocery store
underneath that night
yeah so we we shot that at uh we shot
that in west hollywood i think that he
must have stopped by
vons on the way there and then just
packed it up because he had
pepto-bismol lemon and lime juice
busting out the donut and and there was
more in that bag that will forever
remain a mystery
i i've never seen anything like it i
mean it seems to me there has to be a
and we'll see how i do here but there's
got to be a sense of honor to this
right even if
no performance enhancers no performance
enhancers it's got to be
like no there's got to be something and
i know i'm going to be in tears because
i can already start to feel now my lips
are starting i'm starting to feel my
lips a little bit on my face
um but there's got to be i'm going to
try to do it with honor i want you to
know that god damn it i'm going to try
to do it without
there's an episode recently where
someone asked you i don't remember who
but
uh oh no it was it was will ferrell and
and he was like how are you doing this
and you likened yourself to a sherpa or
something it was a great analogy
that i loved and they were like look if
you were with the
real sherpa climbing up everest and they
panicked uh
that wouldn't help you very much now
would it and so you're there to
are you eating five did you just dig
into five
yeah i did work ahead i think you know
what i think you you mesmerized me with
with the
with the flattering words i lost i lost
where i was
that's the one that's the one all right
i'm going in i don't want to get totally
behind
[Music]
we're gonna have so much fun with center
close
[Laughter]
the bad thing about that one was that i
bit my tongue when i was telling the
joke
hard and i'm feeling hot sauce in the my
tongue
where i bit it uh-oh we got a open wound
yeah all right jeffrey d morgan we have
a recurring segment on our show called
explain that grammar to a deep dive on
our guess instagram
pull interesting pictures that need more
context and with you we have a theme
it's
all with your buddy norman reedus so
i'll show you the picture
you just tell us the bigger story where
did your love affair with the motorcycle
begin and do you guys have a most
memorable road trip together spain was
maybe the greatest trip we've ever had
once a year we like to try to hit the
road and do like a real trip but it's
hard with our work schedules
so like in nashville like a new orleans
florida something like that
a good two three day or that we can kind
of get our
feet up and go um but i've been riding
bikes since i was a kid and and
norman as well funny enough norman and i
have known each other for 30 years
we had the same acting manager 30 years
ago
no joke and then i kind of lost touch
with him and so when i got on the show
it was sort of like oh it's so good to
see you
and i knew that he wrote he knows that i
ride and and it was just
immediate and then we've been kind of
just inseparable since
and we can just go for miles and have
the best conversation without ever
opening our mouths
stonehenge overrated or underrated we've
heard mixed reviews on this show i'm
gonna go with overrated
yeah i'm gonna tell you why it's
overrated because it's because there's
like a
major highway that passes right next to
it like
not like a mile or a half mile it's like
you could
throw a rock at it so it's not that zen
kind of space that you wanted to be it
is very special though
it's pretty amazing that one's hot on
the lips
all right i'm in okay but i'm kidding um
i suppose it's good that i can still
feel my lips so i when they're numb
is maybe when i should be fearful
[Music]
oh tears of the sun that's very hopeful
i'm i'm sensing a
single crybaby johnny depp here
right now from the sun
how do you find out that your character
is dying like do you
literally read it in the script and then
have to grapple with both
the story-driven emotions of all that as
well as your own employment or do they
give you a heads up
yeah oh yeah because i died a lot no
you're right oh man that was like a
running joke with my father it still is
he's like you died you know 127 times he
knows
um when you used to audition you
generally knew your character was going
to die
you know there was probably a dying
scene that you had to do
in a room without an actor with a
casting director
that wasn't going to give you anything
and i was probably just dying my ass off
a million times
you know whether it's taking gunshots or
whatever i would do anything to get the
job and
and they would put you through your
paces back then too man
mortifying [ __ ] grey's anatomy i knew
was something special
that's the one time that i saw my death
coming and was trying everything i could
do to get out of that death
that character danny and that love story
with izzy kind of
took the world by storm i knew how
[ __ ] lucky i was to be there
and i was like please don't kill me i
will do
shonda shonda please don't kill me and i
did i i did i begged her
and that was that's what changed my life
that's being denny where i never got out
of bed
is why zack snyder hired me to be the
comedian
so that's that's how special that was
i could tell that was a bad bite right
off the bat it felt like
a lot of liquid i just think i got a big
puddle of sauce
and it went right to the cut of my
tongue i'm already worried about the
next one i'm already worried about the
next one
that's the bomb man i know oh [ __ ]
yeah this this just changed for me
yeah this has been great i'm thinking
winter claws and comic-con
and now you're not invited maybe
what's the story behind getting matching
tattoos with your supernatural co-stars
jared padalecki
and jensen ackles because it's not often
that you'll see co-stars sort of
immortalize their time together that
permanently we did that
hold on my mouth is burning up
uh we did that at my wedding i'm gonna
have to have my first sip of water i was
trying it
[ __ ] so good
yeah that uh whatever
one okay so uh
we got married my wife and i
we had a tattoo artist come to our
wedding and that show i think lasted a
million years and we just had a very
special relationship
the three of us it was just one of those
things so we got a
very small little crown on our on our uh
wrists what body part is that i get my
mind is starting to melt i'm trying to
hold it together here though
you once described your 2003 role as a
zindy reptilian and star trek enterprise
as a quote job that made you want to
quit acting
can you expand on that
on the nose that's all that quote is on
the nose that feeling was on the nose
um that job was on the nose
uh in a bad way it turns out that i'm
claustrophobic i
had a really hard time doing makeup
process and i had straws in my nose and
i've never been on a set where i went
home at night
and just thought what am i doing this is
i've made the worst
[ __ ] decision of my life i don't ever
want to be an actor again
like i was sure that this was just wrong
and it
almost made me quit it was it was
horrible
[Music]
okay i don't know why i'm so okay
[Music]
i'm trying to let let it touch oh i
already tell
yeah that doesn't even taste like a
[ __ ] sauce that's not like
let's make something delicious
careful careful around the eyes i was
going uh forearm eyes
um wow
see why do people eat that that's like
that's my question
so i think maybe for some people it's
like a
macho thing uh for us it's just for this
kind of moment
that's not enjoyable holy [ __ ]
oh my god so you've amassed a small
fleet of motorcycles and covered
pavement
in every state including some countries
and i know that you have a mustang
nicknamed lucille that even
has the walking dead bat on the trunk
of all the toys in your garage which one
has your favorite custom finish
oh my god probably lucille
probably oh my god i can't feel my face
yeah it's uh oh my god that hurts so bad
i went crazy i thought i was putting
on my son i'm flipping him off
he's taking pictures of me i mean 66
was the year i was born for one i found
this mustang
i wanted to redo it and i did
it's about oh my god it's so hot the car
is hot
and my face it's uh
about 700 horsepower um
on a very light car
[Music]
oh my god dude sean
i lost it i'm trying to focus
you know what we're still connected
we're still connected i'm still i'm
right along with you i'm right along
with you
okay whoa i know with your first big
paycheck from
acting that you bought a harley davidson
what separates harley davidson guys from
like sport bike guys
well i'm gonna say balls um
man
you're a real man with a harley and
you're just [ __ ] joking if you're not
um
there's something about harley-davidson
that nobody can compare to
my first bike was a a night rod a
blacked out night rod special
um it looks like the batman motorcycle
and um when i could buy a new
harley-davidson for me
that was the day that i was a success to
me
you know what i mean it wasn't buying a
house it wasn't uh anything it was
buying a motorcycle
and uh i love riding them there's
nothing i found that is comparable to a
harley davidson on an open road
uh the bomb that's gonna go somewhere
special and so this has the uh womanized
scorpion i like it
all right man you see how red this is
you see the tint of that compared to
number one
and i i i know it all too well
[Music]
i want to say this doesn't taste like
the poison that the bomb did right off
the bat
still tough still tough
why would i say anything we've talked to
a bunch of hot ones guests in the past
about what it was like to grow up in new
york during hip-hop's heyday but i don't
know if i've ever talked to anybody who
was in the pacific northwest
boots on the ground for the explosion of
grunge rock in the 90s
how do you remember the seattle scene
taking shape at that time
oh my god oh my god i'm putting that in
my face i'm trying so hard to
just keep it together here so
none of us knew obviously that that time
in seattle
was going to be the birth of a movement
i mean i don't even know what you what
you call grunge rock it changed the face
of music
i think that the guys that were making
that music marijuana
sound garden were just real artists
and it is now something that we will
tell our kids about
because that was a special time and it
was true art
and if it hadn't been for for that and
it hadn't been for the people that i was
hanging out with there's no way i would
have got into acting i would have never
had the balls
to go into the business that i got into
i wasn't good enough to be in the band
so you know look i'll do uh record
covers or whatever posters for the rock
shows
and then it was like well uh poetry and
then that became
[ __ ] acting um but it was it was all
pulled from the creative
nucleus that was that seattle music
scene and
that's how uh certainly my career was
kind of birthed
[Music]
all right oh [ __ ]
i'm gonna shake it up gotta shake it up
pick it up he knows the shake
i gotta talk you with that last dab all
right
cheers
[Music]
[Music]
well the good news is jeffrey dean
morgan that we've reached the final stop
aboard the scoville express along the
way
we've talked about your many highlights
in acting we've talked about mischief
farm
we've talked about how we're gonna hang
out at santa claus this winter
but before you go i want to take a
little wink at your new film the unholy
with a little bit of a hot sauce tie-in
over the course of this 10-wing gauntlet
we've experienced everything from
heavenly flavors to
ungodly spice levels but through some
divine miracle somehow
some way we've made it to the end which
sauce in this lineup would you describe
as the most
evil oh not even a [ __ ] question it's
exactly the one that i knew was going to
be going in
not even it's not even close this has a
taste
immediately when it hits your mouth that
it says i am poison and will
take you down which hot sauce label
would you describe as the most depraved
one-eyed scorpion one lips active
on a lighter note is there a sauce that
you would call angelic
this one it had kind of the most flavors
and like
for me it had like a hint of lime and my
lips are on fire
an angel in a bottle and look at you
jeffrey dean morgan
taking on the wings of death and living
to tell the tale and now my friend
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you
this camera that camera probably just
the one you're looking at let the people
know what you have going on in your life
we got here's negan on uh sunday
the easter sunday whatever that is
sunday the fourth is that
right and then uh that same weekend on
good friday
is uh unholy the movie um
which doesn't even compare to the balm
and uh
the last dab as far as fear
great job great job there was a minute
there i was like i'm gonna have to duck
out
just for a second to cool throw up
you know i've seen that before i've seen
that
oh dude i had so much fun it was great
thank you so much for having me
hot ones truth or dab the game the kick
comes complete with 250 question cards
and then here's how the game works you
just go around the table
you take turns being the host being the
players
and when you're a player you get asked a
question you have a choice
just like in the show answer it honestly
or suffer the wrath of the last dab and
take a look at this
there's even a mini bottle of the last
dab included i suggest you have napkins
on hand
you have to have some milk on hand and
of course be careful
be very careful around the eyes hot ones
truth or dab the play at home game is
available at shop.firstwe fees.com
heatness.com and amazon play at your own
risk
wings not included
[Music]